Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass, viel zu lange nicht mehr haben wir über La Liga gesprochen hier im Kurzpass und jetzt wollen wir das nachholen, hab ich gerade Kurz-Fass gesagt, ich habe Kurz-Fass gesagt. Wir sprechen mit Jan Platte von der Saunen über La Liga im Kurzpass. Jan, ich grüße dich zum Kurz-Fass.
Ja, ich freue mich beim Kurz-Fass sein zu dürfen, Max, danke.
Das ist immer, hier ist nichts gescriptet, hier ist es nicht ganz so professionell wie bei der Saunen, ich mach das immer alles aus der Hüfte und dann passiert auch mal sowas.
Du hörst anscheinend nicht häufig genug bei uns zu und so, was da so alles passiert.
Aber schön, dass du hier bist in den Rasenfunkstudios, weil wir fast Nachbarn sind, wie nett.
Ja, wir haben es festgestellt beim Telefonieren. Machen wir es per Skype, dieses Interview, oder rufen wir uns an oder treffen wir uns doch. Und dann liegen nur 1000 Meter Luftlinie zwischen deiner und meiner Wohnung.
Ja, unglaublich, was hier in Giesingen an Fußballkompetenz vereinigt ist und damit meine ich aber viel mehr dich als mich. Denn du kennst dich in La Liga sehr, sehr gut aus. Du kommentiertest es sehr häufig und wir haben viel nachzuholen. Das letzte Mal wurde hier im Rasenfunk über die spanische Liga gesprochen nach dem 11. Spieltag. Seitdem sind neun weitere vergangen. Es ist ein großes Leid, dass das so lange gedauert hat. Es gibt aber auch ein paar Dinge, die gleichgeblieben sind. Zum Beispiel Barca auf Platz 1 mit 5 Punkten Vorsprung aktuell vor Atletico. Was hat sich denn bei Barca getan in den letzten Wochen? Vielleicht erst mal sportlich und dann können wir noch über Transfer sprechen.
Transfer ist ein großes Thema natürlich gerade. Und das macht Sinn, darüber gleich zu sprechen. Und sonst sportlich, ja, ich würde sagen, es tut sich gar nicht so außergewöhnlich viel beim FC Barcelona. Sie spielen so ihren Saisonstiefel runter, ohne irgendwie so wahnsinnig spektakulär daher zu kommen. Das ist eine Saison, in der sie grundsätzlich, vor allen Dingen defensiv, gar nicht mehr so stabil und so stark unterwegs sind wie in der letzten Saison. Sie haben sich jetzt, wobei das muss ich auch sagen, in den letzten 7, 8 Spielen haben sie, glaube ich, kaum Gegentore in der Liga kassiert. Ich meine, es waren jetzt sieben Sieger, auch am Stück in der Liga, mit nur zwei Gegentoren sogar. Und ich gucke sie immer gerne, muss ich sagen, auch wenn sie eben gar nicht mehr so wahnsinnig aufregend sind. Sie sind jetzt wieder sehr erfolgreich, sie sind das stabilste Team da oben. Man hat es neulich aber auch wieder gesehen. Ohne Messi sind sie mitunter eine gute, aber eben keine sehr gute Mannschaft. Die Abhängigkeit ist definitiv weiterhin sehr vorhanden. Es ist spannend, was so insgesamt bei denen passiert. Auch mit einem Usman Dembélé, der fantastisch drauf war bis zu seiner Verletzung. Es gibt immer nette Themen.
Was hat Dembélé? Ist es eine schwere Verletzung?
Eine Knöchelverletzung. In 15 Tagen Pause haben sie gesagt, ohne gegnerische Einwirkung hat er sich verletzt und wird bald wieder da sein. Aber er hat ihn jetzt beim Pokalspiel in Sevilla auch sehr gefehlt. Messi wurde geschoren, Busquets gar nicht mitgenommen von Ernesto Valverde, über den auch immer viel geredet, geschrieben wird, bleibt er oder bleibt er nicht. Der hat ein bisschen überrascht mit seiner Aufstellung und hat dann eben weder Dembélé als Unterschiedsspieler noch Messi. Und so kam es dann eben zu diesem 0 zu 2 ins Sevilla, das sie jetzt nächste Woche aufholen müssen, wenn sie denn ins Halbfinale wollen.
Das berühmte Rückspiel. Ja, dann lass doch mal kurz bei Valverde bleiben. Warum wird darüber diskutiert, ob er bleibt oder nicht? Wenn ich mir eben zum Beispiel die letzten Ergebnisse in der Liga angucke, dann ist es 5 zu 0, 2 zu 0, 2 zu 1, 3 zu 0, 3 zu 0, 3 zu 1. Und das waren alles Siege, so wie du es angesprochen hast. Warum gibt es da überhaupt Diskussionen um Valverde?
Der kam ja im Sommer 2017 und hat als jemand auch mit Stallgeruch so eine gewisse Akzeptanz schon gehabt. Aber es gab von Anfang an die Gerüchte, dass die Spieler eigentlich gerne jemand anderen gehabt hätten. Einen ehemaligen Co-Trainer mit Unzué. Und dann war Jorge Sampaoli auch noch im Gespräch, das den die Clubführung eigentlich lieber gehabt hätte. Er wurde es letztendlich und hat dann keinen guten Start gehabt. Falls du dich erinnerst, auch gegen Real Madrid. In den Supercoup hast du verloren. Und hat das dann aber fantastisch gemacht in dieser Saison. Aber hat sich auch getraut, so ein bisschen an dieses 4-3-3 ranzugehen und eigentlich dieses heilige System zu verändern, in dem er vier Mittelfeldleute aufgestellt hat. Deswegen waren sie defensiv so stark wie selten. Sie sind Meister und Pokalsieger geworden, aber nach der Saison haben alle gesagt, es ist doch gar nichts wert, weil Real Madrid zum dritten Mal in Folge die Champions League gewonnen hat.
Das Ausscheiden gegen Rom war natürlich auch bitter.
Das hast du definitiv Spuren hinterlassen. Das hast du auch vollkommen recht. Und er ist natürlich nicht angekratzt gewesen nach dieser Saison, aber es fehlte dann irgendwie auch so dieser ganz, ganz große Triumph. Da sprechen wir von der Champions League. Und da Real das da eben wieder so ein bisschen überstrahlt hat in der Königsklasse, war klar, dass sie in dieser Saison wieder noch mehr auf ihn gucken würden. Und er ist jemand, der so anders ist, beispielsweise eben auch als ein Guardiola, auch selbst als ein Frank Reikart. Und er hatte relativ wenig Emotionen. Ich erinnere mich an den Armbruch von Lionel Messi in dieser Saison. Und der saß dann da draußen und wurde behandelt. Und Valverde geht nicht mal hin und urkundigt sich mal kurz bei demjenigen, der gar nicht mal so unwichtig ist für ihn, wie es ihm geht oder so. Der hockt da immer, der kniet immer da am Spielfeldrand in seiner Denkerpose. Und die mögen ihn schon gerne, aber es ist irgendwie noch keine so richtige Liebe. Dazu wird ihm immer nachgesagt, er steht eher schon auf defensiven Fußball, wo die grundsätzliche Frage daherkommt, passt es gut zum FC Barcelona? Und ich finde, er macht einen tollen Job. Ich mag dem auch gern zuhören in den Pressekonferenzen. Aber es gibt nicht wenige, die sagen, es wäre vielleicht dann auch im Sommer doch Zeit, sich zu trennen. Und er hat sich jetzt auch noch nicht klar geäußert.
Ja, faszinierend. Also letzte Niederlage gab es am 12. Spieltag in der Liga eben, 3 zu 4 zu Hause gegen Betis und danach ein 1 zu 1 gegen Atletico. Und anschließend wurden alle Ligaspiele gewonnen. Also das kann man dann wohl einen Club nennen, der irgendwie dann doch in der Spur ist, auch wenn es zwischendurch mal etwas wackeliger aussah. Und jetzt haben wir eben auch schon ein paar spektakuläre Transfer-Neuigkeiten beim FC Barcelona. Lass mal mit dem anfangen, was auch hier durch die deutschen Medien ging, weil mit Kevin Pins-Boateng ein alter Bekannter zu Barca gewechselt ist. Wie würdest du denn diesen Transfer einordnen?
Ich habe gestaunt erst mal, aber angesichts der Tatsache, dass sie eben auch Munir El Hadadi an Sevilla abgegeben haben, war klar, sie müssten jemanden finden, der im Sturm ab Minute 60, 65, 70 reinkommen kann, auf den Außenpositionen oder auch offensiv auf den Außenpositionen oder im Zweifelsfall auch mal die Ruhepause verordnet für Luis Suárez.
Hatte man da nicht mit Alcacer eigentlich den perfekten Spieler, um den in der 70. Minute reinzubringen?
Ja, hatte man, definitiv. Aber ich glaube, das hat eben Paco Alcacer nicht mehr gereicht. Und der hat keinen so schlechten Schritt getan, wie wir irgendwie wissen. Der hat letztes Jahr, ich erinnere mich auch an ein Spiel gegen Sevilla, hat da beide Tore gemacht zu Hause und saß am nächsten Spieltag gegen Leganés wieder draußen. Also der hatte eben sehr, sehr wenig Kredit. Und jetzt holst du jemanden mit Kevin Prinz Boateng, den ich weiterhin ja eher auch immer noch als Mittelfeldspieler abgespeichert habe. Und es war nett irgendwie in den spanischen Medien zu lesen, die dann gleich als die Gerüchte aufkamen, sie werden ihn holen, seine Torbilanz ausgepackt haben und wann er wo wie getroffen hat. Und die kommen auf ein paar 60 Tore in über 400 Spielen. Und du denkst, ja, also ist das wirklich eure Neun, die ihr als Backup eben für Luis Suárez haben wollt. Aber der hat ja in den letzten Jahren auch bei Las Palmas, spricht auch noch ein ganz gutes Spanisch, aus diesem Jahr bei Las Palmas irgendwie, da hat er es auch gezeigt. Er hat auch 10 Tore in der Liga gemacht, hat häufiger vorne gespielt. In Frankfurt hat er ja auch nicht nur eine Mittelfeldrolle inne. Und jetzt bei Sassuolo, von dem sie ihn ausgeliehen haben, für eine Million, erst mal bis Saisonende, da hat er auch im Sturm gespielt und auch ein paar Türchen gemacht. Ich finde, der passt fast fußballerisch, wieder das F und das P. Der passt und passt fußballerisch sehr gut rein beim FC Barcelona, auch wenn er das jetzt gegen Sevilla im Pokal noch nicht so richtig zeigen konnte, weil es schwierig war für ihn da gegen Simon Kier. Aber ich finde, das macht Sinn bis Saisonende. Und der ist so wunderbar froh und fast demütig. Die Bilder auf dem Trainingsplatz waren schön mit Boateng, der eben ganz anders daherkommt als Opfer, Fanstar und die Geschichten, die wir aus der Hertha-Zeit irgendwie von ihm überliefert bekommen haben. Der ist geerdet. Der war in Frankfurt ja schon so ein wunderbarer Klassensprecher für diese tolle Frankfurter Mannschaft, wie ich finde, mit so vielen Nationalitäten da drin. Und ja, ich glaube, der genießt jeden Tag. Der wird nicht rumsteh'n kann und der sagt selber, ich freue mich, unfassbar da zu sein.
Also ich bin mal sehr gespannt, wie er sich dann auch einbindet ins Spiel von Barca. Also Suarez ist zwar nicht in den Spielaufbau mit eingebunden, aber er hat schon auch immer wieder die Rolle, den Ball zu halten, den Ball weiter zu verteilen. Ob das Kevin Prinz Boateng so gut machen kann, ich traue es ihm zu, aber bei Frankfurt haben wir eher andere Qualitäten gesehen. Also ich hätte eher die Zweikampfstatistik zitiert als die Tore.
Ja, bin ich absolut bei dir. Und wenn sich Luis Suárez verletzt, da fragt man sich ja seit Jahren so ein bisschen, was macht Barcelona denn dann eigentlich, außer Messi ins Zentrum zu stellen, so wie Chelsea das mit Hazard jetzt gerade die ganze Zeit auch beispielsweise macht. Das kannst du natürlich noch tun, aber klar wäre der kein gleichwertiger Ersatz. Und Luis Suárez ist ein Monster, auch wieder in dieser Saison. Man kann auf ihn schimpfen und die Ballverstolperung. Und ach, das ist ein bisschen theatralischer, aber was für ein Stürmer.
Ja, unglaublich. Ja, Kevin-Prinz Boateng, jetzt in La Liga dann auch bei der Zone zu sehen. Ich mache ganz schön viel Werbung heute für der Zone. Dabei ist eigentlich der Rasenfunk werbefrei. Da siehst du mal, was das für eine deine Präsenz hier in diesem Raum ist. Also, aber lass uns noch kurz bei Frankie de Jong sprechen. Da heißt es ja jetzt, da wäre man sich auch schon einig, dass der zu Barca kommt. Das ist komplett fix. Ist das jetzt auch ein bisschen die verspätete Reaktion auf das Karriereende von Iniesta? Ich hab mich gewundert, dass man darüber so wenig eigentlich hört. Das ist ja ein riesenhafter Spieler, der da aufgehört hat bei Barca. Und das wird gar nicht so wirklich thematisiert, zumindest in meiner Viterblase.
Ja, das stimmt. Also wenn man mit Barca, wenn ich mit Barca-Fans spreche, dann vermissen sie ihn auf jeden Fall noch. Und das wäre auch komisch, wenn nicht, nach 22 Jahren, die Iniesta im Verein verbracht hat, sie haben Arthur geholt, der eine ordentliche Rolle, finde ich, spielt. Und das für seine Verhältnisse, wenn er ran dafür auch gut macht. Ja, also perspektivisch ist es sicher Frankie de Jong auch so in Richtung Iniesta gehend jemand. Also auch eine relativ ähnliche Ruhe sagen. Auch sagte Ronald Koeman, sein Trainer aus der niederländischen Nationalmannschaft, wie eben Xavi, wie Iniesta auch unter Druck. Frankie de Jong und ja, du, wie die Niederländer und Barca. Das gehört so ein bisschen zusammen. Wir kommen auch immer mal wieder so ein bisschen mit dem Spielstil von Johann Kreuf in Verbindung.
Oh, das ist aber ganz gefährlich.
Das ist monstergefährlich. Na klar, macht sich auch keinen Sinn. Die Niederländer tun es trotzdem ein bisschen. Also ich meine, wenn jemand mit dem verglichen wird, dann hat er bei Barca automatisch, glaube ich, eine Daseinsberechtigung und PSG und Men's Hitty und alle wollten ihn haben. Und jetzt geht er im Sommer dann zum FC Barcelona. Das ist, glaube ich, sein Wunschverein auch. Und mal gucken, was dann im Mittelfeld passiert. Man hört so ein bisschen das vielleicht Ivan Rakitic, den ich über die Maßen schätze und gut finde, auch für seine Auftritte in den letzten Jahren. Seine Entwicklung ist fantastisch. Dass der dann aber vielleicht auch aufgrund von Gehaltsgeschichten abgegeben werden muss, die müssen ein bisschen gucken, Barca zahlt wahnsinnig viel Gehalt. 73, 74 Prozent der Einnahmen insgesamt gehen, glaube ich, ins Spielergehälter. Das ist ja eine irre Summe und da müssen natürlich auch ein bisschen gucken, wie sie das einigermaßen gesund halten.
Ich hätte ja gesagt, Schalke kann ihn zurückholen, aber wenn es ums Gehalt geht, dann wird es dann vielleicht doch ein bisschen eng. Aber die Rückkehr von Mesut Özil und Ivan Rakicic nach Schalke, das wär's doch. Gut, aber davon abgesehen, lasst uns über den ersten Verfolger von Barca sprechen, nämlich Atletico Madrid. Die sind fünf Punkte hinter Barca und das, obwohl die letzte Niederlage in irgendeinem Pflichtspiel für Atletico aus dem Oktober stammt. Und das war ein 0 zu 4 bei Borussia Dortmund. Seitdem nur unentschieden gespielt oder gewonnen, aber halt ein bisschen zu oft unentschieden anscheinend, sonst wäre man ja näher dran.
Es haben sie ja einen Unentschieden Max 8 in der Liga. Und in der Liga nur am dritten Spieltag gegen Celta verloren. Also das klingt irgendwie, was die Niederlagen angeht, weiterhin so wunderbar. Sie haben wie immer die beste Defensive in der Liga. Ja, aber sie haben so ein bisschen das Problem, Diego Costa ist relativ lange verletzt, schon hat ganz wenig gespielt, kaum, wenn nicht sogar gar nicht getroffen in dieser Saison. Und sie können halt verteidigen. Wir wissen es alle. In Dortmund war es eine Ausnahme. So hoch hatten sie unter Simeone, so gut wie nie verloren. Sie hat irgendwann auch mal vier Gegentore kassiert, aber das passiert ihnen ja sonst nie. Sie stehen für einen minimalistischen Fußball weiterhin, wo es gar nicht zu negativ klingen soll. Aber ich habe viele Spiele von denen gesehen in dieser Saison, wo es ein bisschen wehgetan hat, auch zuzugucken.
Weil? Wegen des Spielstils?
Ja, genau. Jeder wird eben auch dazu verdonnert. Vor allen Dingen gegen den Ball zu arbeiten. Sie haben mit Thomas Lemar, dem Franzosen, jemanden gekriegt, der eigentlich auch gute Gedanken mit nach vorne hat. Aber jeder braucht auch erst mal ein bisschen, um sich zurecht zu finden im System von Diego Simeone. Und sie haben Antoine Griezmann, der sieben Tore in der Liga gemacht hat. Und die zweitmeisten Tore haben ein paar Leute mit jeweils zwei Treffern. Also das zeigt auch schon wieder dieses Hauptaugenmerk. Neun Tore hat Griezmann gemacht. Sie stehen gut da für den Fußball, den sie spielen. Aber es ist auch eine besondere Saison. Weil das Champions League-Final am 1. Juni in ihrem Stadion stattfindet. Du kennst die Königsklassen-Vergangenheit der letzten Jahre von ihnen mit den zwei Finalniederlagen. Ich war im letzten Sommer in Madrid und insgesamt ein bisschen in Spanien und habe auch viel mit Athletic-Fans gesprochen und die haben eine wunderbare Grundhaltung. Auch zu ihrem Club-Heiligen, zu Diego Simeone. Die sind treu auf alle Ewigkeit und keiner meckert auch. Es gibt keine Pfiffe, wenn es da mal wieder ein 1-1 oder nur ein schmeichelhaftes 1-0 gibt. Man weiß, was man von ihnen bekommt. Aber ich habe gesagt, sie wären Meister in dieser Saison vor der Spielzeit. Da habe ich gedacht, dass da noch ein bisschen mehr passiert, weil sie haben Oblak gehalten, den Chelsea wollte anstelle von Kepa, Gaudínez geblieben, Grießmann war schon praktisch vor den Toren Barcelonas, um dann doch zu bleiben. Und ich dachte mir auch, hey, und der Kerl zusammen mit Diego Costa, dieses Wildschwein, Diego Costa, der zurückkam und gar nicht viele Tore gemacht hat letzte Saison, aber so fantastisch passt er an die Seite von Grießmann. Ich fand die ein wunderbares Duo, weil sie auch so unterschiedlich sind. Aber genau, dann hatten sie alle ihre Schwierigkeiten. Sie haben sie mit dem Torschießen. Was haben sie gemacht? 30 Tore jetzt insgesamt in 20 Spielen?
Ja, ich meine, nur 13 kassiert, aber das ist eben die Frage, ob es in dem Fall wirklich geht, wenn man sich so viele Unentschieden holt. Unter anderem das war das spektakulärste zu Hause gegen Girona mit 3 zu 3.
Raus aus dem Pokal durch dieses 3 zu 3.
Genau, unglaublich. Interessante Situation. Wir haben ja noch einen zweiten Verein aus Madrid. Das wird jetzt niemanden überraschen. Über den wird wie immer mehr berichtet, nämlich Real. Da gab es ja auch einen Trainerwechsel, hat jeder mitbekommen. Haben wir, glaube ich, auch schon im Rasenfunk besprochen. Bin ich mir gerade gar nicht sicher, wann der stattgefunden hat. Real mit 10 Punkten Rückstand immer noch auf Platz 1 und 4, 5 Punkten Rückstand, Entschuldigung, auf Platz 2 auf den Stadtrivalen. Was ist denn da los?
Zurzeit erfreuen sie sich wieder an dem Fußball, den sie spielen zumindest, was die letzten zwei Partien angeht. Gestern im Pokal 4 zu 2 erfolgreich gewesen gegen Girona. Und davor haben sie ein ganz gutes Spiel gemacht.
Davor haben sie gegen Sevilla gespielt.
Genau, das 2 zu 0 gegen Sevilla. Dann haben sie, na richtig, du sagst es, das Sevilla 2 zu 0. Das war mit das überzeugendste, dann eben auch in La Liga seit relativ langer Zeit. Also die letzten beiden Spiele waren wieder okay. Ansonsten muss man sagen, unter Santiago Solari hat sich nicht so wahnsinnig viel verbessert. Im Vergleich zu Julen Lopitegui, der nach diesem merkwürdigen Aus in der spanischen Nationalmannschaft dann ja im Sommer aufschlug, ohnehin den Ruf hatte, als Vereinstrainer bei Porto war er mal relativ krachend gescheitert, nicht viel drauf zu haben. Dann kam es relativ schnell zur Entlassung, aber wir wissen eben auch, in so einem WM-Jahr, trotz der ganzen, oder in einer Post-WM-Saison und trotz der ganzen Erfolge in den letzten Jahren, wie unruhig es dann werden kann. Niko Kovac hat das hier bei uns beiden um die Ecke, bei den Bayern jetzt schon mitbekommen, aber immerhin hat man in Madrid keine große Auf-die-Fresse-Konferenz, dann irgendwie abgehalten, die Bosse und haben irgendwie versucht, da ihre Nebelkerzen irgendwie zu zünden. Florentino Perez sitzt das alles so ein bisschen aus, der Präsident, der sehr mächtig ist, der sehr viele Entscheidungen beeinflusst, der, glaube ich, auch einen guten Draht zu Santiago Solari hat. Wie lange der bleiben wird, mal gucken. Letztendlich spielen sie jetzt nicht wahnsinnig viel besser Fußball. In den letzten Partien hatte man aber, hatte ich wieder den Eindruck, dass sie den Spaß zurück hatten. Auch ein Luka Modric hat wieder Lust auf Fußball gehabt. Das ist ganz entscheidend für Real Madrid. Casemiro ist ein bisschen gefestigter. Sergio Ramos hat gestern wieder zwei Tore gemacht. Benzema spielt mit Fingerbruch. Und Vinicius reißt so ein bisschen diesen Trott auf, der sehr vorhersehbar war in den letzten Wochen und Monaten. Sie haben wieder so ein paar Lichtblicke.
Dann natürlich den Weltpokal gegen Al-Ein-Gebot.
Das war ein Wahnsinns-Highlight. Zum 84. Mal in Folge haben sie diesen unglaublich wichtigen Wettbewerb gewonnen. Mal gucken, was da kommt in dieser Saison. Sie haben ja in der letzten Saison, das hat sich auch schon angekündigt, nicht immer gut Fußball gespielt. Sisu hat auch überlegt, glaube ich im Januar, oder vielleicht auch die Verantwortlichen, ob man sich da trennt nach dem Pokal aus letzte Saison gegen Leganes gegen die haben sie sich jetzt trotz dem 0-1 im Rückspiel dann doch mal durchsetzen können. Und ja, die Schwierigkeiten kommen nicht von heute, sind nicht von heute auf morgen gekommen.
Ja gut, das ist natürlich auch die nach Ronaldo-Ära. Aber was mich jetzt interessieren würde bei Real ist fast das das bigger picture, also der größere Zusammenhang. Wir haben eben mit Cristiano Ronaldo, den einen Fixpunkt des Spiels und auch viel Identifikation mit dem Verein verloren an Juventus Turin, die ja übrigens gegen Atletico jetzt dann in der Champions League spielen. Da kann man sich drauf freuen, das wird eine Defensivschlacht werden, wenn du mich fragst. Das wird ein unglaubliches Spiel, glaube ich. Also zwei davon, ja. Aber wenn wir jetzt eben mal den größeren Kontext aufmachen und du eben sagst, Paris sitzt es derzeit relativ routiniert aus. Und die Titel, vor allem in der Champions League, und das ist ja sicherlich noch der wichtigere Titel als der Meistertitel, auch wenn es nervt, wenn den Barca holt, den hat man ja zuhauf gewonnen, also fast schon New England Patriots mäßig, so dass alle nur noch gähnen, wenn sie ins Finale kommen. Aber jetzt gucke ich mir an, was bei Barca passiert, und da sehe ich jetzt, da haben sich ganz, ganz viele stützende Mannschaften ja auch verabschiedet, wir haben es ja schon thematisiert, Xavi, Iniesta, und wir sehen, die rüsten sich für die Zukunft, holen sich eben einen De Jong und so weiter. Was passiert denn dabei real?
Ja, die Zeit der Galaktischen ist eben schon länger vorbei. Möglicherweise bricht sie in absehbarer Zeit wieder an. Also ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich fand das auch sympathisch.
Glaubst du, dass das weiter die Herangehensweise von real bleiben wird? Dass man auch in Zeiten vom PSG, von Manchester City, also von anderen Vereinen, die unglaubliche finanzielle Möglichkeiten haben, weiter einfach versucht, die größten Stars des Fußballs bei sich zu versammeln?
Na, du sagst jetzt, Max bleibt es, das Konzept sozusagen. Da frag ich dich, war es das in den letzten Jahren? Was hat Real Madrid in den letzten drei Jahren für einen großen Transfer getätigt? Und das fand ich auch ein Stück weit beeindruckend, denn es gab die komplette Abkehr von diesen 100 Millionen Transfers.
Das stimmt natürlich.
Sisu, Beckham, Figo und und und.
Vielleicht gab es aber auch einfach nicht diesen einen überragenden Star, den man reale Interesse haben wollte.
Ja, aber vielleicht gab es eben auch einen guten Blick, eben Leute wie ESKU zu holen, Leute wie Asensio zu holen, die schon sehr entscheidend waren. Casemiro hat kaum was gekostet, das hat eine Weile gedauert. Porto, wo er ein bisschen gereift ist, den dann auch zurückzuholen. Du hast immer Ramos gehabt, du hast Konstante gehabt, aber du hast dann die Cavajal zurückgeholt aus Leverkusen, die du selber ausgebildet hast. Dessen Trikot haben sie in den Fundamentstein der Nachwuchsschmiede eingelassen, als der 10, 11, 12 Jahre alt war und gesagt, hier, das ist ein Spieler, der es schaffen kann.
Speaking about no pressure.
Der war ein super Beispiel dafür, wie man es schaffen kann, als Nachwuchsspieler, sich da durchzuarbeiten. Marcelo, das Konstrukt ist ja so gewachsen, neben 2012, glaube ich, Luca Modric von Tottenham, losgeeist für ein paar 30 Millionen Euro oder so. Da ist viel gewachsen, auch in den letzten Jahren. Deswegen, hey, was ist diese Mannschaft, was hatte die für eine Aura? Auch in den letzten Jahren. Ich habe vor einiger Zeit mal in Walde-Bäbers vorbeigucken können, habe Interviews gemacht mit Casemiro und auch mit Toni Kroos. Es ist schon beeindruckend gewesen, was diese Mannschaft, jeder Einzelne, der da auch rumliegt, für eine Ausstrahlung hatte. Es ist einfach ein richtiges Team gewesen. Mit dem großen Häuptling Sergio Ramos, der die Kabine beherrscht. Gab manchmal ein bisschen Ärger, wie man gehört hat, mit Cristiano Ronaldo. Aber die haben sich immer auch für den Erfolgsfall, wenn es mal sein musste, zusammengerauft. Sie hatten, glaube ich, ohnehin eine ganz gute Stimmung, denn sie so ein unfassbar guter Moderator. Man wusste ja gar nicht, wie gut ist er als Trainer. Aber es hat so toll gepasst da in den letzten Jahren. Ich bin gespannt, ob es jetzt die Abkehr wieder gibt. Asensio funktioniert nicht mehr. Isco funktioniert nicht mehr. Das waren die beiden, da waren wir uns alle einig, Max, auf denen Real Madrid fußen wird in den nächsten Jahren. Von Asensio redet keiner mehr. Da war immer das Gespräch, hält er dem Druck stand. Ist es zu viel für ihn? Und er sagt, ich bin noch nicht derjenige, der Real hinten auf dem Rücken nimmt. Und auf geht's im Galopp. Und Isco, auch die Kollegen, beide Sohn, die sich in Italien sehr, sehr gut auskennen. Es ist eigentlich klar, dass der zu Juve geht. Mal gucken, was dann da wird. Ich finde es hochspannend. Barca kauft schon ein, du sagst es. Und das nicht zu knapp. Und Real Madrid, jetzt gegen Ajax auch in der Champions League. Mir fehlt die Fantasie. An den 4. Champions League-Gewinn in Folge zu glauben. Das bleibt unglaublich spannend, was die da machen. Auch auf dem Transfermarkt. Und sie müssen sich ein bisschen erneuern. Es ist natürlich auch immer viel Hörensagen. Aber Luca Modric wollte ja angeblich weg im letzten Sommer. Cristiano Ronaldo hat gemerkt, vielleicht ist die Geschichte eben auch auserzählt. Klar, hat er da unglaubliche 9 Jahre gehabt. Aber der hatte auch aktiv Lust auf eine Veränderung.
Ja, wer weiß auch, aus welchen Motivationen heraus. Da gibt es ja noch viele Nebenaspekte, die nicht nur mit Sportlichen zu tun haben.
Aber Luca Modric hat viele Freunde bei Inter Mailand. Mit Perisic, mit Brozovic, dann ist...
Milinovic Savic. Mein Gott, SMS ist die Abkürzung.
Milinkovic Savic. Dann haben sie genau Virchalko ausgeliehen, auch von Atletico Madrid. Und da gibt es so eine Kroatenfraktion. Ich glaube, das hätte auch super gepasst. Was hat der jetzt mit 33 erreicht? Was hat der für eine WM gespielt? Ich glaube, der hatte auch Lust gehabt, das letzte neue Kapitel aufzubrechen. Jetzt hat er auch Lust auf Real Madrid, was denen sehr gut tut. Ich bin gespannt, was die noch machen. Aber es sieht in der Liga nicht gut aus angesichts von 10 Punkten Rückstand auf den FC Barcelona.
Das ist ja genau der Punkt. Es könnte sein, dass es zum ersten Mal seit gefühlten Dekaden so sein wird, dass Real Madrid irgendwann im April dasteht und sagt, wir sind jetzt auf irgendeine Art und Weise aus der Champions League ausgeschieden, ist uns schon länger nicht mehr passiert. Wie konnte das denn sein? Vielleicht haben sie noch die Copa del Rey, da gehen die aber nicht in den Keller für. Um ein André Brehme-Zitat umzumodeln. Also interessante Phase bei Real Madrid. Was ist denn mit den Verfolgern? Als allererstes, da haben wir ja schon kurz drüber gesprochen, Sevilla, die bei Real mit 0 zu 2 verloren haben, aber ja dennoch nur 3 Punkte Rückstand haben. Was macht Sevilla so gut?
Und im nächsten Spiel haben sie, und das macht die Sache dann eigentlich gleich rund, Max 2 zu 0 eben im Pokal gegen das etwas von Valverde geschwächte Barca gewonnen. Sie waren unfassbar schlecht im Santiago Bernabéu bei dem 0 zu 2 bei Real Madrid. Sie hatten praktisch keine Torchance, eine von Escudero, dem ehemaligen Schalker. Ansonsten haben sie sich da hinten drin versteckt, um dann zu Hause ein relativ gutes Spiel gegen Barca zu machen im Pokal. Es gibt das Auswärts- und es gibt das Heim Sevilla. Und es gibt kaum ein Team, wo die Diskrepanz in der Liga so groß ist.
Kann man das erklären, warum das so ist?
Also, ob es allein die Stimmung ist im Sanchez, Piz Juan, vielleicht ein Aspekt. Ich glaube, sie sind selber auch so ein bisschen auf der Suche für die Gründe. Letztendlich muss man sagen, mussten sie sich auch wieder. Jetzt im letzten Sommer an den neuen Trainer gewöhnen, mit Pablo Macin, der aus Girona kam, da tolle Arbeit geleistet hat eine ganze Zeit lang. Sie haben insgesamt fünf, sechs Trainer gehabt in den letzten zwei Jahren der FC Sevilla. Es gab Birizo, es gab Sampaoli, es gab Montella und jetzt eben Pablo Macin. Und man merkt der Mannschaft an. Das ist immer noch so eine Findungsphase auch, sich jetzt an den neuen Trainer zu gewöhnen, der eben aus einem kleineren Club kommt, der eigentlich auch ein bisschen mehr Wert auf Defensive legt, Pablo Macin. Aber Sevilla war auch immer eines der unterhaltsamen Teams in den letzten Jahren. Sampaoli steht für einen besonderen Fußball, wie wir alle wissen. Montella hatten sie in den Stürmer Trainer. Die sind einfach insgesamt ein bisschen zu wenig gefestigt. Im Mittelfeld haben sie einen Zonzi abgegeben, deren Fixpunkt war definitiv auch für die Ordnung ganz grundsätzlich. Sie haben weiterhin ganz, ganz tolle Spieler. Vor allem vorne auch mit Sarabia, der eine super Saison spielt. Jeda macht einen guten Job, dann ist Andres Silva, den sie ausgeliehen haben, von Milan ganz gut eingeschlagen bis November. Aber dann hat er sich auch eine Auszeit genommen. Sie haben ein gutes Team und du und sie stehen auf Platz 4. Also es gibt eigentlich gar nichts zu meckern.
Und sie haben auch die Bilbao-Wochen hinter sich gebracht.
Dank dem Auswärtssieg im Summer Messe im Neuen haben sie sich durchgesetzt, obwohl sie das Rückspiel auch zu Hause verloren haben. Aber wenn du die Ergebnisse gerade aufgerufen hast, sie haben von den letzten vier Spielen drei verloren.
Ja, ich meine, eines ist ein bisschen abgeschenkt zu Hause gegen Bilbao nach dem 3 zu 1 Auswärtssieg in der Copa del Rey.
Richtig.
Das war noch leicht verkraftbar. Aber genau, es ist eine Mannschaft, die sich irgendwie noch finden muss. Aber es brennt ja nichts an. Und das finde ich gerade das Interessante in der spanischen Liga, dass wir eben aktuell den Stand haben, dass Sevilla, Alaves und Getafe, das sind so die drei Anwärter aktuell um den 4. Champions League Platz. Und da hätte ich, also mit Ausnahme von Sevilla, hätte ich mit keinem davon gerechnet. Kann sich natürlich auch noch drehen. Aber erzähl mir mal ein bisschen was von Alaves zum Beispiel. Wie haben die es denn geschafft, bis auf diesen fünften Tabellenplatz zu kommen?
Maxi, sie sind ungeschlagen zu Hause. 32 Punkte insgesamt geholt und davon 19 im eigenen Stadion. Sie haben mit Abelardo einen Trainer, der genau weiß, was er seiner Mannschaft abverlangen kann. Er hat selber bei kleineren Vereinen gespielt, aber hatte eben auch eine sehr erfolgreiche Zeit. Abelardo hat beim FC Barcelona als Verteidiger eher einen defensiven Grundgedanken. Es ist ein großes Thema in Spanien. Die El Pais hat einen wunderbaren Artikel auch neulich über sie geschrieben. Die Quintessenz ist, sie machen nichts Verrücktes. Er bringt denen keine Tricks bei, die sie überfordern, sondern sie wissen ganz genau, was sie zu welchem Augenblick zu tun haben. Die haben gerade mal 22 Tore geschossen. Also sagen wir mal eins im Schnitt, aber eben auch nur 23 kassiert, was absolut passabel ist. Und die stehen für eine gewisse Effizienz. Jetzt haben sie aber Ibai Gomez verloren, der relativ wichtig war in ihrem Spiel. Den hat jetzt Athletic Bilbao gerade vor ein paar Tagen zurückgelotst ins Baskenland. Also zu sich ins Baskenland. Mal gucken, was da noch passiert. Aber die standen vor 10 Spieltagen, als ihr das letzte Mal über La Liga gesprochen habt, ganz ähnlich da. Ich glaube, es gibt viele, die überrascht sind, dass sie sich weiterhin da oben halten. Sie sind definitiv eine sehr positive Überraschung, ohne dass sie den wunderbarsten Fußball spielen. Ich kann jetzt nicht mit genauen Zahlen kommen, aber sie sind auch nicht klassische Spielverweigerer. Aber die haben wenig Ballbesitz. Die kommen anders daher als die Mannschaften um sie herum. Auch wenn ich dann auf den siebten, auf Bettys gucke, auf diese Mannschaft, die einfach mit den schönsten Fußball steht. Und die Mannschaften, die über ihnen sind, sind natürlich auch noch viel mehr eingebunden, was den Ballbesitz angeht.
Ja, also es gibt nur zwei Teams, die weniger den Ball haben pro Spiel aktuell nach diesen 20 Spieltagen. Und das eine ist Leganes, und über die anderen sprechen wir gleich noch mit Getafe. Aber das ist ein bisschen wie Schalke 04 2017, 2018. Wenn ich mir anhöre, sehr effizient, wissen sehr genau, was sie tun müssen, machen keine verrückten Dinge, schießen wenig Tore, kassieren aber auch wenig.
Gar nicht so schlecht, auch der Vergleich. Also ich habe jetzt im Champions-League-Rahmen hin und wieder die Möglichkeit gehabt, auch mit den Schalkern zu sprechen, auch dann vor Ort. Und ich habe nämlich, dass Christian Heidel auch mal zu mir gesagt hat, klar, als wir in Istanbul standen, am Tag vor dem Spiel, letzte Saison gab es halt viele 50-50-Spiele, die häufig zu unseren Gunsten ausgegangen sind. Und genau, das sieht man auf Schalke, glaube ich, auch weiterhin ganz realistisch. Auch die letzte Saison ordnet man da richtig ein. Und genau, bei der Partie Valaves läuft auch viel, was eng ist in dieser Saison zu ihren Gunsten. Aber sie verdienen es sich, Max, meine Meinung.
Genau, die Parallele geht auch noch weiter. Die meisten Tore nach Standard-Situationen hat Alaves auch erzählt. Und zwar ist das fast die Hälfte. Zehn Tore nach Standard-Situationen, zehn aus dem Spiel heraus, zwei nach Kontern.
Und jetzt guckt mal auf die Elfmeter.
Und keinen einzigen Elfmeter bekommen.
Bekommen? Genau, sie haben keinen gekriegt. Ja, genau, das ist wunderbar. Aber sie verlieren halt Ibai Gomez, der unter anderem auch für Standard-Situationen zuständig war. Sie haben Juni noch mit dabei. Wir müssen gar nicht so sehr über das Personal sprechen. Sie haben mit Kajeri, um das doch noch kurz zu tun, und Baston eben auch ihre Top-Tierjäger, die haben jeweils vier Tore gemacht. Du siehst, die sind nicht abhängig von den Launen eines Mannes da vorne drin. Die verteilen das irgendwie ganz gut. Und die kommen als Mannschaft daher.
Okay, wir gucken mal an, wo das Alaves noch hinführt. Und dann sagen wir mal Getafe mit dem wenigsten Ballbesitz der Liga. Da muss ich jetzt dann nicht nach dem Spielstil fragen, aber ich muss fragen, wie schafft es Getafe dann aktuell, nur zwei Punkte Rückstand auf dem Champions League-Platz zu haben und Platz sechs zu belegen? Kann man es nicht so wirklich erklären?
Sie sind das zweite Jahr jetzt in Folge in der Liga. Und häufig heißt es ja auch, Max, dieses zweite Saisonsyndrom. Das war flix, das zweite Jahr. Aber da zahlt sich dann eben auch ein Stück weit Kontinuität aus. Sie haben mit José Bordalas einen Trainer, der seit 2016 da ist. Der hat Alaves in die erste Liga geführt, um sich dann im Streit zu trennen direkt nach dem Aufstieg. Er ist dann zu Getafe gegangen, um mit denen dann in den Playoffs aufzusteigen. Ich glaube, es gibt natürlich auch immer Ergänzungen, was den Kader angeht. Es gab viele neue Leute, wo ich das gerade auch bei dir sehe, am Computer, die gekommen sind. Aber es steht so ein Grundgerüst. Es ist eine Idee davon, wie ich Fußball spiele. Es ist ein bisschen anders als Sevilla, weil es selber viel Fluktuation gibt. Es ist schwierig, aber es ist eine andere Geschichte. Sowohl bei... Wobei Abelardo kam im Dezember 2017. Aber der hat das schnell implementiert bei Alaves. Und Bordalas ist eben schon eine ganze Zeit da bei Getafe. Und der liegt großen Wert auf die Defensive. Nur Atletico Madrid hat weniger Gegentore kassiert. Beispielsweise als Getafe. Du siehst es, es passt zu dem, was du jetzt auch gesagt hast, mit dem wenigsten Ballbesitz. Das ist absolut ehrlicher, spanischer Vorstadt Madridter, Arbeiterfußball und ja, die haben Erfolge gefeiert. Eben auch gegen größere Mannschaften. Sind im Pokal noch vertreten, haben da, meine ich, gerade Valencia mit 1 zu 0 niedergerungen. Guck du noch mal mit mir drauf. Sie haben nur 1-2 gegen Barca verloren.
Ja, also tatsächlich auch. Das war die letzte Niederlage Anfang Januar und davor die letzte Niederlage, ein 0 zu 1. Mitte November gegen Valencia, die sie jetzt eben mit 1 zu 0 besiegt haben. Aber das hört sich ja schon so an, wenn du sagst, niedergerungen den Gegner, dann scheint das ja mehr Spiele, als nur dieses eine jetzt gegen Valencia zusammenzufassen, die Retafel gemacht hat.
Guck mal, sie haben ein Pokal gegen, nee, in der Liga, Entschuldigung, 4 zu 0 gegen Alaves gehabt, aber in den anderen 8 Spielen da drum herum, jeweils nur ein Tor gemacht in den letzten Wochen. Also du siehst deren Konzept, es ist klar darauf aus, sehr, sehr gut zu stehen, gegen den Ball, gegen den Gegner, sehr aufmerksam, sehr konzentriert zu arbeiten. Und sie setzen das einfach gut um. Also es ist ja auch so ein Verein mit der Geschichte. Wir erinnern uns vielleicht an diese wilden Zeiten.
Olli K bricht Mark von Bommel die Nase beim Torjubel.
2008. 2008. Dieses 3 zu 3 gegen die Bayern. Bernd Schuster war der Trainer. In der Saison direkt davor, um dann zu Real Madrid zu wechseln. Das ist auch ein Verein mit einer Geschichte. Ich glaube, Michael Laudrup war Trainer bei Getafe gegen die Bayern bei diesem 3 zu 3. Also es ist ein Verein, der auch ein paar Geschichten hat. Alaves, wenn ich die jetzt auch nochmal umspringen zu dürfen, Max, auf 5 sehe, mit diesem UEFA Pokalfinale. Anno, dazu mal...
Oh Gott, wie lange ist das her?
17 Jahre? 2001?
Wahnsinn. Ich werde es nebenher recherchieren. War es damals schon die Europa League? Ich glaube, ich hätte noch... 2001 tatsächlich. Tatsächlich. Gegen Liverpool. Genau, genau. Das war das. Ach, verrückt. Wahnsinn. Da hieß das Westfalenstadion noch ganz offiziell Westfalenstadion. Das waren Zeiten des Fußballs. Aber wird denn das thematisiert in der spanischen Presse und in der fußballinteressierten Öffentlichkeit, dass mit Alaves und Getafe zwei Mannschaften gerade aktuell auf den Europa League-Plätzen liegen, die eben einen sehr defensiv betonten Fußball spielen? Das entspricht ja nicht ganz dem Klischee, was man vom spanischen Fußball hat.
So sprichst du das gut zusammen, finde ich. Vor allen Dingen, weil auch in der letzten Saison so viel über diesen wunderschönen Fußball in Spanien gesprochen wurde, der weiterhin praktiziert wird, aber eben auch von Mannschaften, die weit weniger erfolgreich sind. Wenn ich ganz kurz auf Platz 17 zu Celta Vigo gucke, da sind in 20 Spielen ein paar 60 Tore gefallen. Die haben halt 32 gemacht, aber auch 34 kassiert.
Und die waren ja zum Beispiel letzte Saison so rund um den 20. Spieltag auf Platz 7 oder so. Also Celta Vigo hatte letztes Jahr eine Hochphase, kam dann auf 12 raus.
Auf 13 kamen sie raus?
Genau, auf 13.
Aber du hast recht. Sie haben eben immer diesen Kerl, Yago Aspas, auf den sie sich wie sonst was verlassen können. Der hat gerade aber eine Warnverletzung. Die letzten drei Spiele, die sie alle verloren haben, waren nicht mit dabei. Aber genau, die stehen weiterhin trotzdem für diesen spektakulären Fußball. Aber die vergessen halt das Verteidigen. Und das ist so ein bisschen eben auch der Bonus, den sich Alaves, den sich Getafe verdienen. Und natürlich sind die ein Thema. Weniger, würde ich sagen, jetzt in den ein bisschen boulevardträchtigeren spanischen Sportzeitungen. Aber die El Pais widmet sich jetzt nicht umsonst. Dem Trainer Abelardo und dem ganzen Konstrukt der Portivo Alaves.
Und wird das auch gewertet? Findet man das positiv, dass sich da der Fußball weiterentwickelt, dass es eine andere Nuance ist? Wird es eher kritisch gesehen? So wie hierzulande ja zum Beispiel die Vizemeisterschaft von Schalke 04 sehr kritisch eingeordnet wurde?
Da fragst du mich ehrlich gesagt zuviel. Weil, also ich unterhalte mich leider so gut wie nie mit spanischen Journalisten bei den Champions League Spielen. Da gab es hin und wieder die Gelegenheit in London zum Beispiel als Barcelona da gespielt hat. Das war interessant dann auch beim Frühstück im Hotel mit den Kollegen aus Spanien da zu sitzen und eben auch viel über La Liga reden zu können. Aber du, es ruft keiner Buu, wenn jetzt Alaves und Getafe irgendwie eingelaufen kommen, auch in den großen Stadien. Jeder weiß halt, es wird arbeitsreich. Also gegen diese Mannschaft. Und ich würde sagen, meine Einschätzung so aus der Ferne betrachtet, es gibt eher Lob für das, was die leisten. Also der schöne Fußball wird jetzt nicht automatisch prämiert in Spanien und alle sagen, ja aber da muss doch Celta Vigo, da muss doch Bettys auf 4, 5 und sonst wie stehen. Dann können wir auch noch zu Valencia kommen, wobei die in dieser Saison auch ziemlich rumpeln und so. Aber nein, das ist absolut legitim, auch in Spanien mit so einem Fußball Erfolg zu haben.
Dann lass noch kurz über Valencia sprechen. Zum einen, weil du einen biografischen Bezug dazu hast, hast du mir im Vorgespräch gesagt. Und zum anderen, weil es eben einer der bekannteren Vereine ist. Und wenn wir darüber sprechen, dass Sevilla, Alaves, Getafe gerade aktuell die Mannschaften sind, die sich um den letzten Champions League-Platz ein bisschen streiten, Stand 20. Spieltag, dann fehlt ja zum Beispiel eine Mannschaft wie Valencia. Und die haben es geschafft, in 20 Spielen 11 mal unentschieden zu spielen und 19 Tore zu schießen und 18 zu kassieren. Was ist da los?
Ja, das frage ich mich auch jedes Mal, wenn ich, wenn ich die sehe. Wir müssen ein Stück zurückblicken zur letzten Saison. Also Valencia war ja ein Trainerfriedhof. Also da gab es Leute, die sind da irgendwie 5, 6 Wochen geblieben. Gary Neville und andere aufstrebende Trainer, Hoffnungen und auch alte eingesessene, die da nicht lange geblieben sind. Und dann kam Marcelino, der in Villareal jahrelang eine sehr gute Arbeit gemacht hat, bei Villareal und hat sie zurück in die Champions League geführt und hat den ganzen Verein so ein bisschen befriedet. Es gab unfassbare Unruhen auch um Peter Lim, den Präsidenten oder Besitzer. Und ach ja, es war wirklich der Chaos Club jahrelang und dann haben sie letzte Saison fantastisch gespielt. Es haben Leute wieder funktioniert wie Dani Parejo. Die Jungen hatten sich, glaube ich, mal richtig drauf gefreut, wie ein Carlos Soler bei einem Trainer arbeiten zu können, der ihnen wirklich Vertrauen geschenkt hat und durch diese Befriedung des ganzen Umfelds warst du wahnsinnig erfolgreich. Und Schwuppi bist du in der Champions League. Schwuppi kommen viel mehr Anforderungen, viel mehr Erwartungen. Du hast Juventus und Manchester United in der Champions League Gruppe mit dabei gehabt. Sie sind dritter geworden, dürfen jetzt immerhin Europa League weiter spielen.
Gegen Celtic. Sehr schön.
Ja, auch atmosphärisch. Also wohl im Celtic Park, als auch in einem meiner Lieblingsstadien in Spanien, im Mestalla. Und du, dann guck ich, was habe ich gemacht. Vorbereitungsspiel gegen Bayer Leverkusen vor der Saison. Gewinnen sie 3 zu 0. Das war so die offizielle Saisoneröffnung. Ich dachte auch, Mensch, ihr seid aber gut in Form, Herr Marcelino. Und da dachte ich auch, okay, das macht vielleicht sogar Sinn, dass sie Kevin Gameru, da hatten sie noch Interesse, den haben sie dann aber auch wirklich geholt. Dann tauchte plötzlich, genau, der winkte von der Tribüne, Michi Batshuay, da von seinem Sitz im Mestaya nach unten und wurde sozusagen offiziell vorgestellt. Und ich, ach, auch mit Jonas Hummels, mit dem ich ja viele Spiele kommentieren darf, kann gequatscht. Was machen die eigentlich da gerade im Angriff? Verstehst du das so ein bisschen? Sie haben Simone Zazza abgegeben, der unfassbar beliebt war, der Italiener, und hatten eben Rodrigo Moreno am Ende dann noch behalten können. Real Madrid hatte mal überlegt, ob sie vielleicht die 120 Millionen für ihn zahlen, spanischer Nationalspieler mit brasilianischer Herkunft, viele Tore gemacht. Santi Mina, ein großes Talent im Sturm. Und wir waren uns eigentlich einig, dass ein bisschen viel da vorne passiert, aber okay, dann haben sie halt vier Superstürmer und jetzt haben sie 19 Tore, wie du sagst, nach 20 Spielen und sie kamen eben von Anfang an in so ein Fahrwasser-Max und nicht mehr raus aus dieser Bredouille. Es gab Gerüchte um Marcel Lino, muss er dann vielleicht doch wieder bald gehen. Jetzt hat er sich gerade so ein bisschen freigeschwommen wieder, auch durch drei Spiele ohne Niederlage jetzt bis zum 0-1, jetzt bei Getafe im Pokal. Sie stehen auf 9 und sie haben nur 5 Punkte Rückstand, wenn man es positiv sehen will, auf Platz 6. Also selbst der vierte Platz ist nicht mehr so weit weg, aber sie haben komplett ihre Leichtigkeit verloren. Condovilla, von Inter ausgeliehen, jetzt auch fest verpflichtet. Bei Inter hat mir der nie gut gefallen, wenn ich den gesehen habe. Ich dachte immer, Mensch, der ist so in Frankreich so hochgelobt gewesen. Er hat fantastisch gespielt in der letzten Saison. Es hat zwar so viel, was gepastert, jetzt haben sie aber auch Murillo an den Verteidiger im Winter abgegeben, an Barcelona und ja, die suchen alle so ein bisschen so ein tolle Talente wie immer. Ferran Torres ist 18 Jahre alt, großartige Nachwuchsarbeit, immer schon gehabt. Und ich beobachte die seit 2002, seitdem ich da mal ein gutes halbes, dreiviertel Jahr gelebt habe. Immer ein bisschen mehr auch und ja, ich war selber verwundert. Ich habe gestern auch mit dem Kollegen Uwe Morave gesprochen, der sie auch ganz viel kommentiert hat in dieser Saison. Der hat auch gesagt, ja, das ist erstaunlich, wie wenig von denen kommt.
Gut, aber so ist das manchmal. Manchmal geraten Mannschaften in einen Strudel, dann kommt noch so etwas wie eine Mehrfachbelastung mit dazu. Wir hatten bei Valencia schon in der letzten Folge thematisiert, dass sie so viele Unentschieden hatten, denn so ging ja die Saison los. Also bis zum ersten Sieg hat es tatsächlich bis zum siebten Spieltag gedauert. Bis dahin sechs Unentschieden, eine Niederlage. Also nicht Fisch, nicht Fleisch, da weißt du auch nicht, wo du stehst. Und jetzt stehst du eben auf Platz 9. Es gibt aber noch Möglichkeit, den Anschluss nach oben zu wahren und es wäre ja ganz schön, wenn sich mein Trainer halten würde.
Finde ich auch. Bin ich komplett bei dir. Aber Rodrigo Moreno hat drei Tore bislang gemacht in dieser Saison. Santi Mina 2, Michi Bacuay, der jetzt, glaube ich, möglicherweise zu Monaco geht, wo sie ja gerade Thierry Henry rausgeschmissen haben wieder nach 20 Spielen. Der hat einmal getroffen. Camero hat auch nur zweimal getroffen. Sie haben das Problem, dass sie keinen haben, auf den sie sich gerade verlassen können. Das war vorne eben ganz, ganz anders in der letzten Saison. Aber ich bin sehr bei dir, auch was das Vertrauen angeht, auch aus der Ferne. Nur betrachtet würde ich Marcelino und Valencia gegenseitig sehr wünschen, dass sie beieinander bleiben. Aber ich hoffe, dass sie es tun. Anderes Beispiel, weil du auch gesagt hast, oder jetzt nochmal den schlechten Start von Valencia in die Saison auch sinnbildlich mit dafür reingenommen hast, wo sie, dass sie sich immer noch so ein bisschen in einer schwierigen Situation befinden. Athletic Bilbao, ein weiterer absoluter Traditionsklub, die haben das erste Spiel gewonnen, um danach 13 nicht zu gewinnen, haben dann Berizzo entlassen. Und da geht es jetzt wieder so ein bisschen aufwärts unter dem neuen Trainer, den sie aus der zweiten Mannschaft hochgeholt haben, Garitano. Aber das hat halt echt lange gedauert, so aus diesem Schlamassel des Saisonstarts wieder rauszufinden. Und da haben wir einige Mannschaften, die sich in dem Fall ein ähnliches Bild abgeben.
Ja, Bilbao, die zweite Mannschaft mit elf Unentschieden nach 20 Spieltagen. Also da sieht man ja schon, die Parallele ist ja fast schon zu plakativ. Abschließende Frage, nachdem du auch hier mit zwei eng beschriebenen Seiten Notizen hergekommen bist und wir ja aber doch eher wieder über die normalen, üblichen Verdächtigen gesprochen haben. Wen gibts denn noch, auf den du die Hörerinnen und Hörer gerne hinweisen würdest? Gibt es noch irgendeine Mannschaft, einen Spieler, eine Personalie, die du besonders interessant findest?
Ich guck vor allen Dingen Bettys auch gerade gerne beim Fußball zu, aber da bin ich einer von ganz ganz vielen in Spanien auch. Ich hab ein Fable in jedem Fall für Joaquín, der gleich nächsten Monat 57 wird oder so und weiterhin ein Fußball spielt an der Seite von einem Luchelzo, von einem Canales, der als Riesentalent zur Real Madrid gegangen ist mit 19, 20 von Jose Mourinho, nur ein paar Spiele Zeit bekommen hat, sich zu zeigen. Das hat nicht funktioniert. Und jetzt hat er sein Glück gefunden da. Und die spielen den wilden Fußball auch nicht immer erfolgreich. Da werden sie auch für kritisiert, aber Kike Setien wird mitunter schon als Barca-Trainer im Sommer gehandelt. Da gibt es auch irgendwie Spekulationen. Und da kann ich nur jedem sagen, guckt euch die an. Das macht auf jeden Fall Laune. Ansonsten, ich freue mich sehr auf die Rückrunde, weil alles so eng beieinander ist. Villarreal ist 19. Die habe ich kommentiert im ersten Spiel, das war das Nachholspiel in diesem Jahr von Real Madrid. Da haben sie 2-2 gespielt, zu Hause in La Caramica und Santi Casolle hat zwei Tore gemacht, dem beim Fußballspiel zuzugucken, in dessen Gesicht zu gucken, nachdem wir den 2-2 Ausgleich gemacht haben. Es gibt wunderbare Geschichten, auch rund um die alten Leute. Dann gibt es Talente, auf die man gut gucken kann. Bei Villarreal, das ist ein Samu. Bei Valencia habe ich Ferran Torres schon angesprochen. Es gibt hier und da Leute, bei denen es sich lohnt, dabei zu sein. Espanol mit dem Trainer Rubi. Die waren nach zehn Spieltagen fast europamäßig unterwegs. Jetzt haben sie noch eines der letzten neun Spiele gewonnen. Es gibt zu viele Geschichten. Athletic Bilbao unter dem Trainer, der aus der zweiten Mannschaft kam, bleiben durfte. Mit Iñaki Williams, der gerade aufzockt wie ein Wilder. Ika Mouniajin, der seit Ewigkeiten Wahnsinnstalent ist, aber mit jungen Jahren auch schon Kapitän geworden ist und eigentlich den Talentstatus jetzt auch so ein bisschen abgestreift hat. Jeder Verein hat spannende Geschichten. Letzte Saison ist zum Beispiel keiner, der Aufsteiger abgestiegen hat. Am Ende Malaga Las Palmas und Deportivo La Coruña erwischt. Jetzt ist Huesca mit elf Punkten, also zehn Punkte Rückstand auf Platz 17 auf Celta, so gut wie weg. Dann hast du Rayo Vallecano auf 18, du hast Valladolid auf 16. Also das wird schwierig. Es könnte sie alle drei erwischen, weil also Villareal und Vigo sind sozusagen zwischen den Aufsteigern.
Aber es ist wahnsinnig eng. Darauf hast du mich schon vorhin aufmerksam gemacht. Zwischen Platz 18 und Platz 8, sechs Punkte. Das ist ja wie in der zweiten Liga in Deutschland. Faszinierend. Das wollte ich damit nicht sagen. Ich wollte nicht La Liga zur zweiten Liga.
Nein, das wollte ich jahrelang mal woanders entklemmen. Ich weiß, was du meinst. Ja, also das spricht dafür, guck mal, Villareal. Also die sind jetzt 19. mit 18 Punkten. Und wenn es einigermaßen super, super gut läuft, dann werden die vielleicht siebter noch. Weil das sind gerade mal 11 Punkte Rückstand auf Betis. Also wenn da jetzt ein bisschen mehr zusammenspielt und Gérard Moreno, einer meiner Lieblingsstürmer in der Liga, den sie für 20 Millionen gekauft haben vor der Saison von Espanyol, der aber nur ein paar Mal geknipstert, jetzt vielleicht doch irgendwie zurück zum Tore schießen findet, dann ist da einfach so wahnsinnig viel möglich. Und ja, es ist, manche sprechen vom Schneckenrennen, auch gerade in Spanien, aber in der letzten Saison war glaube ich das Bild so zwischen Platz 4 und 14 gar nicht mal so anders. Jetzt ist es so ein bisschen unterschiedlich, jetzt ist es eben bis Rang 19, jeder relativ viele Punkte hat. Und ja, es wird wunderbar, bis irgendwann rein in den Mai. Und spannend wird natürlich, wie machen Barca, Real, Real Madrid und Atletico, das in der Champions League, du hast die Aufgaben nach angesprochen. Also es gibt viele Themen rund um La Liga.
Ich merke das. Du bräuchtest deinen eigenen Podcast, Jan, damit du das auch mal alles loswerden könntest, was da raus will.
Ja, das stimmt. Ich komme langsam ins Reden. Was machen wir in der zweiten Stunde?
Ja, den nächsten Kurzpass, weil der Kurzpass ja ein Kurzpass bleiben soll. Aber ich kann mich sehr bei dir bedanken. Und ich kann allen Hörern und Hörern nur empfehlen, dir auf Twitter zu folgen, wo du als jp-janplatte zu verfolgen bist.
Ja, das kann jeder machen, wie er den möchte. Aber genau.
Da wirst du am meisten Feedback bekommen, denke ich. Liebe Hörern und Hörern, gibt Jan Rückmeldung jp-janplatte? Warum eigentlich die Doppelung zwischen...
Ich glaube, es gab Jan Platte irgendwie schon. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wer diesen merkwürdigen Namen irgendwie verwendet für seinen Twitter-Account. Aber ich meine, das gab es. Aber ich muss ja sagen, Max, vielleicht lag es auch an mir. Und ich habe es einfach nicht geschnallt. Technisch ist ja manchmal so ein bisschen ein kleines Problem vorhanden.
Okay, also da musst du auf jeden Fall noch eine Legende drum stricken, die ein bisschen, also die dann zwar unehrlich ist als das, was du gesagt hast, aber das war jetzt ein bisschen zu unspektakulär. Bis zum nächsten Mal hast du dir da was überlegt. Ich hoffe, dass ich dich nochmal hier begrüßen darf in den Rasenfunk-Studios. Würde mich sehr freuen. Wann kann man dich das nächste Mal hören?
Ähm, Sonntag. Barcelona in Girona. Ein Verbi Katalan. Und ja, 16.15 auf The Zone. Seid dabei.
Macht es, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörern. Dir, Jan, vielen herzlichen Dank.
Dir auch, Max.
Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen, lieben Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Es gibt die nächste Schlusskonferenz am Montagnachmittag. Es wird auch einen weiteren Kurzpass in der nächsten Woche geben. Mindestens einen, vielleicht sogar zwei. Seid gespannt. Es geht also weiter, immer weiter hier im Rasenfunk. Und wenn ihr uns unterstützen wollt, dann erfahrt ihr alles dazu auf rasenfunk.de/unterstützen. Habt eine gute Zeit. Wir hören uns wieder. Bis bald.